Boris Johnson may have won a convincing
majority at the election but there are
still questions about what his
government plans to do with it because
the concept of party manifesto was not
exactly stuffed full of detail what to
try and work out what we can expect from
her five years of Boris Johnson we're
joined now by Alex Crowley a former
Downing Street adviser to the Prime
Minister and Boris Johnson's biographer
Sonia Pernell thank you both very much
for being with us so that's the question
I guess isn't it and Alex what do you
think what can we expect from Boris
Johnson government now that he has
effectively got such a big majority that
he doesn't have to compromise a
parliament I think we have the potential
to see if you like an overhaul or most
of Britain's economic model you
reference the manifesto being in your
words light on detail I actually don't
think it was that light on detail if you
look at all those policies and you stand
back you start to get a sense of what he
wants to do when we were doing the
leadership campaign together and his
analysis of the referendum result was
that basically it was a collection of
towns and cities outside London and
southeast who had been let down over a
number of years finally having their say
about wanting change that change didn't
happen over the last three years because
of the political gridlock this election
has swept away that political gridlock
and this gives Boris the opportunity to
deliver the change that those people
voted for you say that you don't agree
the assessment that the manifesto was a
lot in detail at the same time though
the Institute for Fiscal Studies for
example saying as a blueprint for five
years in government the lack of
significant policy action is remarkable
it wasn't radically reforming was it
it's be honest the manifesto by its
necessity it's a safety first my sworn
mistakes however let's look at the some
of the ideas behind it right our
economic model in this country for a
number of years has been London in the
southeast getting most of the investment
and then the Treasury thinking well then
we'll redistribute it out to the regions
get a bit of EU money in as well what
Boris is talking about is saying
actually no let's put that investment
into the regions and
and the nations as well outside of
London and southeast and could you
imagine what would happen to this
country's wealth and prosperity
if those regions and nations have the
same levels of prosperity as London the
South East if you could raise those up
and this is when he says he says
levelling up if you could raise those up
to the to the standard that we have in
London and South East the entire nation
would benefit that's a very different
economic model Sonia what what's your
sense I mean you've seen the manifesto
you've you've worked with Boris tones
and you've studied him through the book
that you wrote on him
what kind of promise did you think he's
gonna be well look I mean that was a
spectacular when you have to
congratulate him on that he is the
supreme election winner of our time
quite clearly what he's less good at and
what we're less sure of is what he will
actually do in office as London Mayor we
look back at his track record as long in
Mayor he was called by his own side that
they do little mail sometimes even they
do nothing they're after winning it was
very um frustrating he did very little
with that great mandate that he hadn't
in London so it's really not clear what
he's going to do now he's under enormous
pressure as Prime Minister there has
been all this pent up feeling clearly
he's got to do something about it but
let's look at the landscape for that to
the brexit deal that he's proposing in
his own advisers of opinion will
actually contract the economy so where
is this money going to come from he said
that he's not going to raise taxes
throwing some of it will come from
service it'll come from borrowing but
when this is a lot of borrowing and you
know we are we actually in a fit state
to take on that amount of borrowing how
our kids and our kids kids may well be
paying for it so the economic model
doesn't exactly it's not sort of whole
because how are you going to make the
money house I economy going to thrive
with this really quite difficult deal to
raise kind of money to make this kind of
investment I think the investment is
absolutely necessary that's quite clear
but is this the way to go about it's
interesting to hear it's funny they're
saying Boris Johnson was known as I kind
of do little and there I mean you could
argue that actually being a figurehead
for government is not necessarily a bad
thing if you have a team around you that
does the actual work and the
the investigations and reform is that
your experience of what it was like
working for Boris Johnson yes IIIi I
wouldn't entirely agree that he was with
with us on these assessments of his time
as mayor and perhaps understandably what
was his greatest strength as a leader
and his greater strength as a leader it
is his ability to inspire confidence
that is the essence of leadership and
when you for anyone who has worked with
him and around him the thing that marks
him out is that everybody around him
wants to impress him so he's a bit of a
delegator did you say delegated but
someone who makes you raise your game he
did it as mayor he restored confidence
in London I forget when he took over as
mayor London and the rest of the country
was coming through the financial crisis
and and although London suffered
comparatively less than in other parts
of the country it still had its problems
he restored confidence his team around
him wanted to do better and that is a
very powerful thing if you apply that to
the entire machinery of government he's
got he's got our whole cabinet who's
wanting to impress him other people
wanted to come into in cabinet and
deliver for him he's got the NHS and the
leaders of the NHS they want to deliver
for him that is a very very powerful
thing and that should not be
underestimated well I mean first of all
I mean it was his own side he described
him as the do little mayor but I think a
lot of people remember a lot of people
have resigned rather than work for a
Boris government but what presidents and
government and a lot of the big beasts
of Parliament have gone he's lost an
awful lot of talent in part through his
own actions
you know eject some people from the
party because they wouldn't follow his
line on on No Deal a lot of those sort
of big brains big experience people have
gone so it's quite interesting I will be
really interesting to see he was going
to put in his cabinet when he does the
big reshuffle I'm not sure who's there
who's left with that great track all
that great brain that experience and how
to pull the levers of government
actually how to make things happen
because that's not easy it takes a while
to learn how to do the other thing that
really does worry me and I've worked
with him myself I was his deputy way
back in the 1990s we were reporting and
the EU
what woody worries me and what I really
hope now changes and he can do this if
he wants to is to stop being that
secretive person to stop being that
person who won't Brook any opposition
who won't Brook any scrutiny now we do
need to see him take on the really tough
interviews we need to get him to to
start also to respecting Parliament he's
got this big majority but he needs to
take much more notice of what Parliament
says we now hear that he wants to tinker
with the Constitution perhaps curtail
the powers of the Supreme Court and we
also hear that he wants to get rid of
some civil servants and bring in
external advisors instead we hear that
he wants to remove the licence fee from
the BBC and perhaps come down hard and
Channel four as well these are all very
worrying things why is he scared why is
he not allowing proper scrutiny of what
he's doing do you think Boris Johnson's
somebody here is perhaps trying to rein
in the power of Parliament and putting
it back into number 10 and is that a
concern I things will change this was an
election about to change what's gonna
change he he's been very clear in his
manifesto about what he wants to do and
you reference the Constitution actually
I think the proposals in there were
quite sensible that he wants to look at
how the relationship between Parliament
and the courts is going to work in the
future yes you can say well that may be
a risk to the Supreme Court I don't
think anyone's talking about that I
think we should be able to pull that
quite up I'm hoping okay we go yeah
there we go at page 14 the conservative
manifesto after bricks that we also need
to look at the broader aspects of a
constitution the relationship between
the government Parliament and the courts
no I mean some people will look at that
and be concerned yeah look so I think
what that's referencing is you had a
situation where the Supreme Court made a
very politically contentious decision we
won't rehearse the legalities of this
now if you're going to get into a
situation where the courts are
increasingly getting involved in
political matters then you do have to
ask where does the accountability lie
and there the proposal in the manifesto
is saying well let's look at that let's
have a debate about that let's let's ask
where where the boundary should lie I
don't think that's talking about
anything too drastic and just because we
are having too much time left and
it feels like people trying to work out
which Boris Johnson they're gonna get as
Prime Minister is it going to be the
Boris Johnson that someone like that
Hancock wants to see the one nation
Boris Johnson is it going to be the
person who the European research group
want to see and the more right-wing and
the brexit air prime minister which
Boris Johnson do you think we're going
to get he's going to portray someone
isn't he I mean he can't keep all of
those people happy I think his instincts
actually probably more one nation but he
will go for whatever suits him and
whatever it will keep him in power and I
think you're more likely to see the
Boris Johnson that you've seen of recent
times again repeating refusing to
apologize the fact that he called women
wearing the cab
you know bank robbers and he talked
about EU citizens being outrages the way
that they treated this country as if
it's their own that is not a one nation
Tory and I suspect that is the bottoms
and that we will have very quick thought
what do you think you're going to get
the Boris that that people voted for
someone who's going to champion the
regions and the nations outside London
is gonna be tough on crime he's going to
get us out of year okay thank you very
much we're out of time and thank you
both very much for your analysis